deixo meu pequenininho e vou passar pelo
pequenino não se riam já se começaram a
rir já no direito agora caiu
isto é uma adaptação do bandolim
isto é uma adaptação do bandolim e como
não podia ter os instrumentos todos os
outros alunos para uma disse parece uma
guitarra elétrica em miniatura ou seja
gols naquilo que já era uma adulteração
um instrumento vai viver baseado num
instrumento acústico e passou para 9 com
essa alteração passou se para o tipo de
instrumentos acústicos e são em crianças
bastante o centro que vai aumentar e
diminuir o volume é que vários
potenciamos pelo lar para circular na
briga pela frente este quiz ou
magnéticos
o som enfrenta o cazaquistão
separaram-se explicações captado com
piadas o som seria mais semelhante ao
cavaquinho
então vamos lá ver o que é que eu tenho
aqui mas estes instrumentos do painel se
desligar o som isto é que vocês não não
tem som acústico você não vê nada e
também tem suas vantagens ou seja o som
não realimenta o que aqui o que é que
isso vai alimentar o quanto uma caixa
harmônica all-star amplificar o
instrumento o som que está a ser o
ambiente está ruim entrar na caixa
harmonix pode criar um look um ciclo que
vai criar feedback um aumento
indesejável do volume de som
isso não tem caixa harmonia que isso não
acontece e eu neste após utilizar o tipo
de outro tipo de sons como é o caso da
instituição
i
numa autêntica guitarra elétrica
pronto é posso ter os mesmos defeitos
que estava a utilizar no cavaquinho
e alguns algoritmos matemáticos que são
utilizados neste período eletrônicos são
feitos mais a pensar neste tipo pick up
com os kiezos são instrumentos que
comercialmente têm mais saída e as
companhias esse facto em empresas têm
que ganhar dinheiro não é o mesmo assim
isso funciona mesmo assim então
separarem neste instrumento eu tive que
fazer uma adaptação própria minha para
amplificar até tenho que muita gente se
lembra de tudo neste você já que a
partida
reconhece instrumento com não há nada de
especial nem eu estranho porque
visualmente com vocês é normal já viram
muitas guitarras elétricas
mas este instrumento fato é muito
estranho que eu tenho aqui picapes tudo
bem e todos os todos os defeitos que
usei qual cavaquinho que usei no
cavaquinho foram efeitos que foram
retirados mais um instrumento
electrónico bem eu vou por aqui
a emoção do pit por exemplo
você para o efeito aqui são muito mais
eficaz do mundo 1
o tchan peça em baixo elétrico emoção em
lei
o youtube
ok e pronto está em relação aos defeitos
outras coisas foram evoluindo né não a
perspectiva eletrônica e hoje em dia já
é possível tocar com este instrumento
com o cavaquinho tocar com sons dos
instrumentos o meu caso
sei lá após a uribe com os matemáticos
que um identificam a nota
outro cara e transformam essa nota num
sinal mire-se lá eletrônica que vai dar
uma instrução é um outro programa o
programa pra esperar contaminado sempre
ouvi nada é a gravação está a ser mais
desenvolvido e almeida que os
processadores dos prédios ficam mais
fortes a menina conta que é mais forte
mais qualidade nesses nesse serviço
musical temos
ok eu tenho aqui um projeto no som
não sei qual é um samba rock então vou
tentar tocar por cima de som com esse
som
ah
isso é tudo menos um banho lá eu posso
chegar aqui e queria fazer o som do
violino os flor escola aqui aqui pra
trás pra frente só queria violino e
tocam violino vai saltar aqui algumas
coisitas por exemplo que não têm e
pronto temos que aprender a utilizar
como é o caso das pressões que
se não tiver seu olhar para mim
provavelmente iriam pensar que ter um
violino
eu posso cara com wilson em simultâneo
estranho né
depois de feitos mais radicais
agora só para terminar a efeitos mais
radicais será eu por exemplo o cara como
uma orquestra de cordas com o meu
anjinho mas lá ver se consigo fazer isso
já é uma coisa mais arrojada eu escolhi
não quero aqui
trim trim
ok a programas que nos permitem fazer o
que estou a fazer é impune e que estava
apenas fazendo dias mas já estão mesmo a
programas mais arrojadas que me permitem
fazer isto em polifonia mas agora eu
consigo
é
isso não é um bandolim pronto e muito
isto eu vou agora se calhar vou passar
aprontou um instrumento geralmente
enfrenta é pra acabar vou passar é o
também tocam instrumentos de sopro é
nomeadamente a minha gaita falls
mas vamos apresentar hoje uma gaita
fonte oficial
aqui é uma gata forma desenvolvida em
portugal uma caneta com buracos com
sensores
então vou ligar e estou-lhe da mesma
forma acho que não vou precisar do
mostrar seu som direto é do próprio
instrumento
acho que não vou precisar desligar
hálito e então este instrumento chamas
tri no treino porque o treino é um uma
forma popular de dizer trillo que é um
musical para designar um efeito musical
vamos lá ver a situação se estressam é
bom né
não estava sabendo conciliar você leva
pilhas é é
é um dos problemas da eletrônica pode
ser esse estilo de música de um
protótipo não é para ter uma pilha você
não tiver som eu mudo pilha e eu
provavelmente irá assunto esperemos
equipe e eu não sei se elas elas são
gastas e que pode ser vai ser
ainda bem que não há regra que a música
também é isso é alegria e boa disposição
esperemos que ela funciona agora já sei
porque é que não está funcionando
o material tem sempre razão
é pedir a via está boa
peça uma gaita
obrigado pronto era isso que eu tinha é
assim
resumidamente podemos estar aqui muito
mais tempo mas acho que já passei um
caso limite do tempo
havia muito mais coisas para vos mostrar
a este facto isso tem a particularidade
de ser um instrumento meio em portugal
eu chamo isto uma gaita sem folgas
espero até não estava
foi um prazer